TRYING TO SOLVE. THE ZONE.
NOBODY DIVING, THOUGH, AROUND
THE PERIMETER DIVING IT IS.
THERE IT IS. THE KID.
>> READ LEBRON JAMES IS COMING
TO THE NATION'S CAPITAL.
>> AND HAS PASSED THE MAILMAN
KARL MALONE AND IS NOW NUMBER
2 ALL-TIME IN SCORING IN THE
HISTORY OF THE NBA.
>> THE FOUL CALL HERE IS WE
GET ANOTHER LOOK AT LEBRON
MOVING INTO SECOND PLACE HIS
LAST BASKET. NICE DIVE. I WAS
JUST TALKING ABOUT NOBODY'S
MOVING. LEBRON SAID, HEY,
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT. I'LL
DIVE DODGERS GETS THE EASY
DEUCE. AND THAT PUTS HIM ALL
ALONE. AND NUMBER 2. CROWD
JUST MADE AWARE TO GIVE HIM A
STANDING OVATION, JUSTIFIABLY
SO.
FORMER TEAMMATE. KCP. ONE
A CHAMPIONSHIP TOGETHER. SURE
IT WILL BE A HUMBLING MOMENT
FOR LEBRON.
>> NOW, KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR,
THE ONLY ONE IN FRONT OF THE
KING WHO WILL GO TO THE BENCH
AND HE'LL BE GOING BACK TO
CLEVELAND. NEXT GAME. WHAT A
MOMENT FOR LEBRON JAMES.
NUMBER 2, ALL-TIME SCORING IN
THE HISTORY OF THE LEAGUE.